welcome back the labour party has been
embroiled in
yet another row about anti-semitism
after the bbc's panorama program made
allegations
that the leader's office had interfered
in disciplinary cases
well one of the party's most senior
jewish mps day market heads joins us now
from westminster mr very good morning to
you
good morning to you you will of course
uh have seen the bbc panera
panorama documentary and indeed the
response from the labour party
itself what were your thoughts on
hearing that first person testimony from
former labour staffers i mean to be
honest nile it's hard to express what
i'm
feeling because i was of course
devastated by it
but i don't know how often how many
people
how many incidents of anti-semitism we
have to
have on our television screens or in our
newspapers
for the party leadership to stand up
and really listen there seems to be a
dogged determination
not to listen and i think my main
feeling out of that program
when i watched it was how young
everybody was
these are young committed idealistic
labour party activists and labour party
workers
and they have been crushed by what has
happened to them
and the final thing i felt was it was
utterly deplorable
and a complete abuse of power for the
leadership's reaction
simply to to try and pursue these people
uh with lawyers and trying to uh to shut
them up
i used to chair the public accounts
committee
and um in those days whistleblowers
were really important to revealing all
sorts of stuff to us and i well remember
when we had the luxembourg leaks about
tax avoidance
or the falciana leaks about tax
avoidance in switzerland
both price pricewaterhousecoopers and
hsbc
responding by taking action against the
whistleblowers
trying to shut them up i never thought
that my labour party
would do the same about whistleblowers
trying to expose
and deal with racism in the labour party
and the response from the labour party
specifically about those
those whistleblowers as you describe
them is to call them
disaffected staffers with political axes
to grind well
i think anybody who watched that program
would have seen that they are committed
honest people with integrity who care
um about the labour party and out if the
fact that three of them
in that program had been driven into
mental health conditions
one had had a break down one had
suffered from depression
and one had contemplated suicide
for the labor party hierarchy for the
leadership of the labour party
to dismiss that as disaffected workers
i think is intolerable and unacceptable
it's a real
abuse of power and i think the labour
party should really reflect and think
again
stop this dogged determination to ignore
stop thinking they've got everything
right and they and they can
uh they don't have to listen to the rest
of us stop being blinkered about it and
pursuing the project at the expense of
really
fighting racism within the party i mean
the labour party itself is pretty
categorical about this they've doubled
the number of staffers that are working
on complaints actually when you analyze
the number of members that this refers
to it's an
infinitively small percentage of the
overall party
that some of these allegations have been
politicized i mean what more could the
party do
say that last but again i said and some
of the allegations have been publicized
what more then given the doubling of the
staffers the tiny fraction of labour
members this
uh references but what more can the
party actually do
now it's about a year since i first
confronted jeremy corbyn about the issue
in the lobby of the house of commons
coming up to the university of year and
the terrible truth is that
in that year things have got worse and i
can tell you from my own social media
you can see from people coming that in
the papers today you have another
whistleblower
you have small cases in the papers day
after day after day
more cases are coming out what can the
labour party do
well it's very easy i think the first
thing i would do
is adopt the alisa campbell uh
code of disa discipline disciplinary
code the alistar campbell disciplinary
code let's call it that
so that if there is a clear instance of
um anti-semitism and a lot of these are
absolutely blatant
and obvious if that happens then you
immediately
expel and the individual would have the
right of appeal that's the first thing i
do
the second thing that i would do is
immediately adopt
a totally independent complaints
mechanism
because it is clear that the current
mechanism
has been abused it's been corrupted by
political influence
from the leader's office and from the
leadership of the labour party
and it no longer holds good third i
would stop this action against the
whistleblowers
that is outrageous we cannot have that
and fourth i will do what tom watson has
been calling for
we're in a really serious position this
is deeply damaging to labour's prospects
we're being investigated by the ehrc
on the grounds of anti-semitism and none
of us know
what the party is saying on all our
behalfs
to the uh equal and the the
the commission so i would publish that
in the way that tom watson has
been asking us to so that we have real
openness instead of secrecy
uh we don't we have that and we
transform that culture
which at the moment i think is so deeply
damaging to labour party
we used to be a tolerant party we've
become an intolerant party
we used to be open and democratic we've
now become
secretive and we've become intimidating
we used to be anti-racist
and we are now allowing a culture of
racism
sorry to interrupt on that point i mean
you mentioned the encounter that you had
with the leader of your party you know
called him an anti-semite and a racist i
mean do you stand by that
well to be honest i've seen nothing in
the past year that has caused me
to change my mind both in the incidence
of anti-semitism that have emerged
and in the further details that we have
of
uh of jeremy corbyn himself the sort of
people he's met
the fact that uh uh that um he went to a
wreath laying
with some terrorists from terrorists but
you're still in the party i mean and if
there
were to be a snap election called in the
next few weeks you presumably would be
campaigning
for the labour party for the man that
you described as an anti-semite and a
racist
to be the next prime minister listen
i've been a member of the labour party
for 57 years it seems a heck of a long
time
and for 54 of those 57 years
the party has been one of the great most
important things in my life
a love of my life and i've had arguments
in it
i've promoted it i've worked with it to
pursue the
uh the values that i have you don't give
up on a relationship
just because there have been three or
four years now of a period
which i cannot support and i have felt
hugely uncomfortable with
i do think we are at a tipping point i
do
think that if the leadership doesn't
start to listen
now there will be many more people who
will feel
so uncomfortable within the labour party
that uh
that they can no longer remain within i
myself
just feel that it's like a marriage
you've been there
i've been there for 57 years 54 years of
complete happiness
i'm going to fight to be shipped before
margaret i mean there are lots of people
who would say if you discovered that
your husband was an anti-semite and a
racist that might be grounds to divorce
what i hope to do is to ensure that you
go
back to the values that brought me into
the labour party when i first joined
i'm myself and an immigrant and that has
been a huge im you know
formative influence on my politics and
my values
so i joined the party because it was an
anti-racist party
i joined the party because it was a
tolerant party i
joined the party because it had an
international uh
solidarity which part of its uh values
and i'm gonna fight for those values i
think you stay
you you try and bring that party back to
the values
not only for me but actually for my
constituents
who depend on everything the labour
party stands for
for their quality of life and for
greater equality
uh uh and greater fairness in our
society
i wonder if i might ask you about your
colleague tom watson um a number of
people have
complained about his behavior this week
was it right for tom watson
uh to criticize jenny formby while she
was undergoing
chemotherapy we know what lynn
mccluskey's views are and are in all of
this and so we could keep it clean
given that it's not yet 10 o'clock in a
sunday morning
um i listen we all want jen we all wish
jenny fornby well
it's terrible to have to undergo this
treatment um i
you know i had a year caring for my
husband when he was going through cancer
as well
so i know exactly what she's uh going
through
but i have to say that the part it's a
you know there are more people
responsible than jenny formby
uh there's the whole of the national
executive
there's the leader of the party there's
a shadow cabinet it's regretful that
there isn't a member of the shadow
cabinet on your
program today to answer some of these um
issues
it's a butt doesn't stop with one person
and i actually applaud
tom watson he's been very he's been
calling this out for a long time
he i think and i share this view that we
are fighting for the soul
of the labour party and i'd just like to
say one final thing i'm writing to the
labour party
all the time about incidents of
anti-semitism
and when jenny was first ill i i didn't
write to her
i wrote somebody else and i got a
response to that letter saying the
matter has been referred
to jenny formby so you cannot you know
it's very difficult in this situation
and i hope that others will now take the
lead and
leave her to uh to you know cope
with the treatment that she's undergoing
but you cannot
fail to deal with this issue and tom
watson is
absolutely right to be calling this out
this is extremely serious
and it goes to the heart of what the
labour party stands for
and the values that uh it promotes do
you think then
that the labour party is structurally
institutionally
anti-semitic now i think
that there is a culture within the
labour party that has
created a tolerance and a
a tolerance of this form of racism
that is now spread through you see too
much of it
you see it in too high you know whether
you talk about chris williams and
whether you talk about pete wilson
whether you talk about the checks that
were done or not done
on our candidate in the peterborough
by-election it is
a embedded culture at the top but what i
also know
and see is thousands upon thousands of
labour party members
who share the values that i'm talking to
you about this morning
who abhor the jew hate
that has now uh been allowed
to sort of come from the fringes into
the mainstream
of the party so i i think that
the labour party it's most people in the
labour party
abhor what is being allowed to happen
what has been given permission to exist
in that in the leadership uh cohort of
the people
at the moment running the labour party
dave margaret hodge many thanks for
joining us thank you
of course we did contact the labour
party and invited them to respond
to the latest allegations they sent us a
statement which says the
following the labour party takes all
complaints of anti-semitism extremely
seriously
and we are committed to challenging and
campaigning against it
in all its forms all complaints about
anti-semitism are
fully investigated in line with our
rules and procedures
and any appropriate disciplinary action
is taken
the rate at which anti-semitism cases
are dealt with has increased
more than fourfold since jenny formby
became general secretary that statement
from
the labour party